- Dans le vignoble
Rivière du Chêne, on se prépare
déjà aux vendanges. Ce domaine
vient de doubler sa superficie.
Il dispose maintenant
de 36 hectares, emploie près de
40 personnes et produit quelque
300 000 bouteilles par an.
DANIEL LALANDE, vigneron prop.
vignoble Rivière du Chêne
- Comme on est souvent
en rupture de stock, bien,
il faut gérer nos inventaires,
il faut gérer notre croissance.
Comme je l'ai précisé,
c'est une industrie pratiquement
naissante. On juge qu'on
va doubler nos surfaces
d'ici 5 à 10 ans.
- Au cours des cinq dernières
années, l'industrie viticole
québécoise a doublé
sa production annuelle
de bouteilles et le nombre
d'hectares de vignes cultivés.
YVAN QUIRION, président,
Conseil des vins du Québec
- C'est un tsunami.
Donc, 800 hectares actuels,
un peu plus de 100 vignobles
avec pignon sur rue et
2,5 millions de bouteilles
qu'on produit. On va monter à...
Notre objectif, c'est
10 millions de bouteilles
pour 2030.
- Le succès des vins québécois
s'explique par plusieurs
phénomènes. Ils n'ont cessé de
gagner en qualité, ils séduisent
une clientèle de plus en plus
jeune et ils profitent
d'une meilleure distribution
dans les épiceries et
les succursales de la
Société des alcools du Québec.
- C'est les jeunes milléniaux
qui ont mis le spot sur
notre industrie, sur
la qualité de nos vins.
Et là, toutes les générations
en achètent tout d'un coup
- Les vignerons ont investi
des millions de dollars dans
leurs domaines pour les agrandir
et les protéger des rigueurs
de l'hiver. Ils se tournent
maintenant vers le gouvernement
québécois pour qu'il investisse,
lui aussi, dans cette industrie
en plein développement.
- Il faut avoir des aides
à la plantation pour nous
aider à développer, justement,
cette viticulture au Québec
parce que c'est une culture qui
valorise également nos terres,
comme elle crée énormément
d'emplois.
- C'est créateur de beaucoup
de bonheur. Et il va falloir
que le gouvernement réalise
que c'est sa responsabilité
sociale que de supporter
ces entrepreneurs à créer
de la richesse pour partager
ce bonheur-là dans
notre société.
- Yvan Quirion croit que
la viticulture québécoise est
promise à un très bel avenir.
- J'ai l'impression qu'on
est un nouveau vignoble très
innovateur, très... très
intelligent dans sa démarche
puis vraiment, réellement
écologique. Faut qu'on soit
transparents et honnêtes.
Parce qu'on compétitionne
15 000 vins étrangers, on peut
pas être autre chose que nous.
- Des vins authentiques et
de qualité, donc, qui n'ont pas
fini de séduire bien des palais.
Ici Catherine François,
Radio-Canada,
Saint-Jacques-le-Mineur.